Film Courage: How did you learn story
structure? Zach Zerries, Screenwriter:
Initially learned in NYU. I had a screenwriting
professor by the name of Stephen Siegel
who was tough but fair and he was a stickler for
not just story structure but format. To this day
I still have his voice in my head a little bit
when I 'm writing. I became maybe at
times too wedded to certain formatting
but he really taught me the bare bones
of how to write a script. I think
when I was young again it was that urge just
to start writing not to really think about
the story and plot it out. I think it became much
clearer to me about how to again story structure,
character development as I got older and got
out of film school but he definitely planted
the seeds that I then sort of sewed
later on as I again evolved as a writer.
Film Courage: When you left film school did
you…I know you said that you realized at
some point that New York was probably not for
you at the time… did you think that you would
get a job working in a production company,
what was in your mind that you as a career?
Zach: For me it was to just be in the business
and see where I could go I was pretty fortunate
because when I came out here I had a lot of
interviews right away I had so my first job
out of NYU had been at Writers and Artists which
I was purchased by Paradigm probably maybe even 20
years at this point but they had a New York and
LA office and they had a a nice stable of like
James Gandolfini at the time was repped by
them they had some other fairly name actors
and the New York the New York agents rep like
they I think they actually had may have had
half the cast on Sopranos so they wrecked
a lot of broadway and film and tv actors
so that was my first job out of school
when I moved to la I initially was
interviewing at management companies and other
agencies I knew I didn't want to be an agent
but I thought just getting the experience
and learning the business was most important
I worked at I cm for
about a second it was literally a second it
was probably three days I worked for a very
big talent agent there and quickly realized
that I was just not going to cut it so
My roommate at the time I was I remember
walking out I cm and just breathing a sigh
of relief because I had I feel like a monkey
had been off my back so I 'm like okay I know
there's no way I 'm going to work in the agency
business at all or Matt as a manager that I
just can't do it I'm not cut from that cloth
there's a certain type and I am not he or she
so my roommate at the time for whatever reason he
had been sent a job opportunity as a writer's pa
on this fox show at the time and I went in and
I interviewed I got the job and then the first
day my first day there the show was canceled
oh no so it lasted a couple more weeks and
it was they the same production
company was producing this comedy
and it was a sitcom that they are they were
developing uh it was an Ed Burns pilot and
I remember because it was the same company
they were saving on supplies so we brought
the supplies from I was at sony at the time
I moved the supplies to uh the cbs radford
and I walked in I said hey you guys are starting
do you need a a pa a writer's pa they're like
actually we need a pa and I was like great here's
my resume and I got the job and I worked for about
a month and I was a night pa and I have to say
like I've worked some very interesting jobs but
driving in LA at night was just this it was a it
was a I don't want to use the word mystical but
it was it was definitely an interesting experience
because at that time this was just I mean people
had email but a lot of executives and other
writers wanted the actual script delivered
so I was going from Pasadena to as far out
as I may have gone to Malibu and this was
like I think I worked like 27 hours straight
but it was but it was wild it was fun like I
learned the lay of the land doing that at
night it was I was kind of on my own I was
driving probably 80 90 miles an hour in my
little Chevy Cavalier all around the town
but it was an experience and it was really it
was a lot of fun and I learned a lot and anyway
long story short that pilot was uh being shot
and I had a friend who was working at law and
order at the time and he said there's a writers
a writer's production assistant job open on
this new law and order show there it was criminal
in tent and they said do you are you interested in
I 'm like yes I would love to because I think this
this pilot I s ending and I they're shooting the
pilot it hadn't been picked up at that point I was
like yes if it's permanent I love it and I wound
up getting that job and I was a law in art on the
law worked on the law and order shows for close to
two years so I had that background in television
and then from there I got in to research and
I worked and working at fox for many years as a
research analyst while I was still writing and it
was my day job but I always was able to find jobs
that supported my writing and and I was able to
one fed the other and yeah it was it was
definitely uh back to your question about the
business and and getting in to it it was it was
definitely I I always knew I wanted to write and
the but keeping an open mind on the day job type
led me to in a lot of different directions and I
had a time where I did temp and attempt
in marketing attempt in post-production
I worked in post-production I had an array of
different jobs and while I was still writing and
always always putting in the time and and that's
now I s has definitely paid off but anyone
who's coming out and trying to get in the film
business I would say sign up with the temp agency
work in an agency or management company you may
like it maybe writing's not for you and you may
decide you are cut from that cloth to be an agent
uh but it 's a I think it 's just a matter of
keeping as open mind as possible in learning all
different aspects of the business while you're
continuing to hone your craft did the driving job
the driving pa job did that in spire any stories
for scripts no no it was it was just again
I was pretty new to la so I was still like
again just I think I was just focused
on learning the terrain at the time
and I do remember I was working on a script
that I again earlier in my career one of the
mistakes I made was working working scripts
over and over and over again until it 's like
look enough you've written this written 20
different drafts it 's all coming out the same
maybe just need to put this in the drawer
and step away and start go for something else
beating your head against the wall isn't I I
don't obviously I s not productive and I know
that if you have a really great idea and you love
it and you're you're you're really wedded to it
that's great but sometimes the best
thing you can do for a script that
you're wedded to and you really want
to tell but it 's not working I s just
to take a step back and put it away and start
and work on something else I know again early
in my career I should have done that with a few
scripts where I 'm like I 'm just focusing I 'm
I 'm beating my head against the wall and
and that was that was about working harder
not smarter at the time and in hindsight
those scripts the best thing those things
those scripts could have used was was better
structure better uh better plotting and more and
a better outline and I hadn't really fully evolved
to that place where I was able to really put to
write an effective outline and and really explore
the story that way I think I was just so quick to
go right to jump right in to the screenplay and
it leaves yourself open to a lot of problems.
Questions For The Viewers:
How did you learn story structure?